[Musique]
une autoroute qui ressemble à un fleuve
en crue
voilà à quoi ont été confrontés des
centaines d'automobilistes sur
l'autoroute a9 hier conséquence
plusieurs voitures ont été emportées par
la puissance des flots de réchauffement
climatique provoque des catastrophes et
augmente l'ampleur des catastrophes et
le nombre de ces catastrophes et
finalement l'écologie radicale est la
seule manière de nous protéger contre
cela et là on voit il est tombé
l'équivalent de deux mois et demi de
pluie en trois heures soit tenez vous
bien 200 litres d'eau par mètre carré
dès la semaine prochaine nous réunirons
la commission de catastrophe naturelle
avec la ministre de l'ecologie pour
déclarer monsieur députés l'a souhaité
déclaré l'état de catastrophe naturelle
je serai ce chef de l'état qui ne se
dérobera pas je serai ce chef des forces
de sécurité je serai ce chef des forces
de sécurité je serai ce chef de l'état
je serai ce chef de l'état je me dirais
ni je ne suis pas candidat ni je suis
quand ce que si vous dites je ne suis
pas caché que vous retournez sur ces
news j'ai bien compris il a des qualités
il a des idées qui veut rentrer dans
l'arène qu'il y rentrer mais moi je vais
pas passer mon temps à commenter les
intentions de quelqu'un qui n'est pas
encore candidat eric zemmour est un
homme seul c'est un commentateur
aujourd'hui de grand talent de grand
talent mais et qu'y a t'il autour de lui
tout seul il est tout seul arrêtons
parler de zemmour arrêtons de parler des
fantasmes qui l'agité par ont des
problèmes manifestement qui sont
prioritaires chez les français ça sera
aussi une façon peut-être de moins de
parler zemmour pourquoi vous ne voulez
pas en parler tout de suite alors que
c'est un sujet qui est règle débat
depuis longtemps parce que c'est un
sujet qui est instrumentalisée donc moi
je veux le poser un sujet qui est
utilisée qu' au bon je sais pas vous est
ce que vous n'avez pas entendu un
certain monsieur zemmour ce qui est une
bonne chose mais voyage qui sera
candidat non mais c'est une bonne chose
s'il le souhaite mais si vous allez on
ne peut pas être en même temps candidat
et en même temps chroniqueur parce que
ça rend une forme d' équilibre qui est
aussi un gage de démocratie
soit je rejoint le camp des êtres
humains et main et je dis mon dégoût de
zemmour soit je ne dis pas et tous ceux
qui me détestent ce fois que les mains
et affirme on vous l'avait bien dit
eric zemmour bonjour eric zemmour
présence d'eric zemmour eric zemmour et
eric zemmour ki moon est ce que
finalement on n'en fait pas trop
aujourd'hui autour du cas eric zemmour
vous rétablir y est et la peine de mort
ou pas
je suis non non je n'hésite pas je ne
saurai pas au pouvoir en plus c'est très
complices les jeunes et abolir la peine
de mort je ne pense pas que on est bien
fait d'abolir la peine de mort
maintenant j'ai la peine de mort
philosophiquement oui pourquoi la france
on a combattu la france ont attaqué la
france ont avisé la population les
civils mais en réalité on n'a rien de
personnel à leur égard on a visé la
france et rien d'autre les avions
français qui bombardent l'état islamique
ne distingue pas les hommes les femmes
et les enfants on a voulu que la france
subisse la même douleur que nous
subissons quand on va exécuter les
terroristes du bataclan en syrie sword 2
de françois hollande on a rétabli la
peine de mort donc on le veut on le fait
sans le dire zemmour a été créée par ce
phénomène de cécité volontaire il est la
punition
du politiquement correct et je crois que
toute une partie de la classe politique
de la classe médiatique et de la classe
intellectuelle devrait faire son examen
de conscience
quand françois hollande a décidé de
bombarder l'état islamique il savait que
sa décision comportait des risques et
que des françaises et des français
allait rencontrer la mort j'essaie
d'être le plus clair possible je sais
que mes propos peuvent choquer earth et
surtout les âmes sensibles le but n'est
pas d'enfoncer le couteau dans la plaie
on dit souvent que je suis provocateur
mais moi ce que je veux c'est être
sincère avec ces gens là ne pas leur
mentir